I messed up I was Russian jail owls and
puke yeah me some hijacking my video if
I have to vomit then I'll find Alex
alright there we go
got it down quick smoothie first and
then start the day okay we're at Nina's
parents place having our breakfast usual
Tim Hortons breakfast Hayden I get that
hash brown sandwich Oh name is doing a
little bit of a cheat though it's even
having broccoli that's not just Russia
what else is in there all right it's a
Sunday so we clean up around here and
Nina's made us some special smoothies
they're green so it's kale and a bunch
of fruit and vegetables what I mean what
else which is this the what I said
bunch of fruits and vegetables vegetable
specific vegetable it's not hijacking my
video love you snack time some yummy
green peppers mmm who likes green
peppers you know yummy hey tin no green
pepper what are you looking up Dracula
well
havens gonna drop put some pictures to
drop not super hungry but it's kind of
snack time pork and mushrooms oh my god
the mushrooms are so good
Hayden wants them to know Hayden's
drying can I see what you're trying
whoa wizard vampire yeah wizard with
what's all the red stuff a spell I feel
like lightning red lightning
super-powerful okay just got back from
salsa teaching level six an amazing
social I forgot to bring a camera with
me I didn't
I barely ate my dinner I ate a little
bit I think it's tilapia with spinach
super yummy I'm gonna finish that still
on when I protein didn't leap umph
good dancing new conversations changing
lives and ready for a relaxing night now
I'm sixteen grams of protein behind for
the day so Nina made me a smoothie
I am over and done for the day day 22
another day another shake captain down
almost down to 30 excited to see how we
do
a 22 alright time for lentils usual fare
alright smoothie time it's green so it's
kale first off for the lunch time pork
chop mushrooms broccoli mmm alright at
TDS about to start work on class Alex an
ace over there I'm four three two grams
of pork to eat probably not good to eat
right before workout but you know
after but then whatever enough I need
you to do the work done well a little
bit no a little bit okay just pork dirty
guns of course we'll see we'll see I
think I'm gonna do it
please some if I have to vomit then I'll
find Alex this shirts already yellow
anyway itself Oh got home from a workout
of TBS time for another smoothie you
know time units made some yummy
cauliflower ground beef and salmon
together this is half of what I have to
eat do that that's sitting there on the
frying pan so time to chat down all
right I'm already kind of full but it's
time for bowl - I've never actually had
salmon and gobbling together but it's a
really good mix another quick smoothie
it's red so it's beets
that's for tomorrow and that's Nina we
love her she's special
day 23 starts like everyday protein
shake
yesterday was 20,000 631 steps excited
for another day
I'm rushing to get on a hangout with Tim
Tim Schmoyer we do a weekly hangout but
smoothie time it is purple so it's beat
based and gonna type in one hangout down
now into another hangout with Tim does
the one that's gonna go public gotta
quickly eat some food usual lentils and
an egg scarfing it down all right so
it's book day I'm at Whole Foods working
on my book promotion and I picked up a
copy from Whole Foods and lunch is gonna
be some tilapia and some spinach excited
to get to work it's 7 o'clock just got
home how's it taking you at the
acupuncture if you could fix her back
and I'm hangry because I haven't eaten
in a while I'm getting angry and
agitated so excited that at dinner time
we've got a pork and mushrooms 30 grams
protein another 30 grams of protein on
the salmon and spinach
I think eat right now so Nina asked if I
wanted a salad and I said of course this
is a special salad what's on here and
puke tell-alls and puke
yeah thank you cover pickles I say oh my
god pickles and this fruit right the
melon and then olives and mixed greens
mmm it is 10:48 at night I'm 24 grams of
protein behind and I just happened to
have one scoop of my protein if so I am
good for the night's day 24 into our
last week another smoothie sorry another
protein shake almost 26,000 steps
yesterday so pretty solid last week last
week last week gotta hit it here we go
all right practice time usual breakfast
two cups of lentils and an egg and a
smoothie it's red so it's beets so
hungry
I didn't dive in film day at studio got
a coffee like four hours sleep so I need
this today because it's film day that's
what it's all about
alex is joining me today first time on
film day first time on field day
Jason super excited lunch is in here
I'll open it at some point we got salad
and mystery meat just wink at me yeah
why so lunch time finish the video some
awesome session I realized I think I
brought too much and I don't want it to
go bad I'm not quite sure what to do I
have a tilapia that should be 30 grams
and then some awesome salads with the
pickles and the mush and the olives and
stuff but then I look in here and
there's two more packs in each pack
associate 30 grams I know I'm uh
supposed to eat 90 grams for lunch so oh
I don't know each pack is 30 grand yeah
so I brought too much I'm gonna figure
what to do maybe she can have one when
she gets here I messed up I was rushing
so I'm gonna have to eat all three fish
so it doesn't go bad cuz there's no
fridge here at TDS 90 grams of protein
serious lunch serious much
I offered Alex a fish yeah Alex of sushi
I take the smell like the fishy smell
but you can handle sushi yeah but my
gosh it doesn't have that pungent fish
smell right you know no my mom you do
cuz you I can smell it on you right now
so it's they're punching this you know
go right in your nostrils yeah yeah yeah
so don't want to say you pass out passed
out I don't even know what happened I
put the food in front of it you just
left food yeah I passed that I passed
that I didn't sleep much last night you
woke up fourth day I came home I worked
out in winter pants because I didn't
bring like clothes and I pushed it too
hard and I was super full from the 90
grand super through the bunch
I see everything used to seeing the day
I had to even lunch
it's crazy I'm still super full it's
almost 10 o'clock I have to go to
Toronto dance salsa ever meeting two
meetings and I still have to have more
protein I'll just have a drink
I'm 24 grams behind in a drink is 24
grams so I'll just do that when I get
back
still still I woke up and like felt like
a truck hit me it is so hard to wake up
it's so hard to wake up anyway
I gotta go I gotta get to the meeting
mmm-hmm bye bye
all right closing in on midnight just
got back 24 grams of protein behind so I
made a protein shake probably not the
best thing to do is drink a protein
shake just before going to bed but
sticking to the diet we'll see where it
leads us this is a new protein shake you
know it's a different color this is all
plant-based so finish this off bedtime
wake up another day morning another day
another smoothing the new smoothies keep
calm smoothie protein shake the new
protein shake only has 19 grams of
proteins of 24 like the other one but
tastes good and it's all vegetarian so
we'll see how many steps yesterday
22300 six another good day time for
lentils lentils and eggs YUM
all right lunch time looks like a mix of
vegetables green beans carrots mushrooms
and pork send it again okay say that I'm
here what am I having
so I get my pork oh there's beans
another two extra salt all right next up
salad another protein shake cuz I'm
behind on my protein and to fold you
anything else
and it's 10:30 is night drink it down go
to bed welcome day 26 usual start do it
every day I have to mix this this is not
mixed yet the protein shake yesterday
steps 20,000 and 95 just hitting ready
to start another day alright bunch of
time lunch time sometimes breakfast time
usual also smoothie time this one is
orange so it means it's carrot based
pretty excited haven't had a carrot one
for a while
I love the carrot smoothies alright it's
Friday Jay your eyes in the house yo yo
using a stand-up desk
yeah brought me uh coffee there it is
same I like the Jay on the Jason there
who's Jason yes no next time Jay rise I
like it
Jay right Jamie delicious it would not
be Jay all right well I'm feeling the
coffee thank you alright lunchtime
really late lunch four o'clock tuna and
salad with pickles and olives and a
bunch of yummy stuff honey
it's dinner time then sauce the time I'm
eating that we haven't the pork poultry
sour pork and salad how many how much
they have that's 90 that's my name XD
that's 60 and you have 30 yeah you have
one piece I have three how is this it's
dinner friend okay
this is Nina everybody look at us
look at the stocks just past midnight
got back from a tds outing tons of fun
lots of great dancing tired
Nina's photobombing my video I'm 19 no
18 grams of protein behind so I got a
drink 19 more and then good day 27 in
the house for almost there
Saturday super excited off to the skanda
knob it's a it's a spa it's about an
hour and a half out of the city relaxing
that has a back ache so she's yawning
right now and she's naked
so cameras on me friends you know
starting the day with a protein shake so
if we're excited we're closing in all
right usual weekend tradition is
eustress Alex my usual sandwich
breakfast sandwich sausage Egg McMuffin
from its importance croissant and
chicken salad
Wow going all wow that's a big breakfast
friend and then our two coffees and our
hash browns yeah I'm statues so the
spine there being a bust we drove an
hour and a half to find out there's a
five-hour wait so we did some shopping
and came back it's now time is it it's
late like three o'clock
we haven't eaten anything since so we
gotta eat Dean is making us a salad with
turkey slices on top that's our lunch
Nina made an awesome smoothie look at
the size of this thing from the
hofbraeuhaus glass in Germany this is
kale since it's green that's how I know
is it spinach or kale let's go green is
kale red is beat and oranges carrots
I know it's yummy pomegranate time
all right dinner is tuna with eggs and
in a soup like mix and it looks like
there's sausages or oh these are
mushrooms mmm yummy excited to try so we
went to we went to an open house
anniversary party for our friends at
catalyst training systems China a super
and on this video it's a 2 year
anniversary a lot of junky food at that
party but we kept it safe I just had
some chicken in some pulled pork and I'm
still a little bit behind so one last
protein shake and tomorrow is way day
see how I'm doing
it's day 28 good morning good morning
something means that it finds away
ourselves every Sunday you know showing
off the muscles before Hey look at that
whoa hello like it's a big thing you
know last week was 121 point for 120 140
for around that lava Jets last and you
did yeah we went to a party last night
121 points 5 you know we're not me and I
went up how does that feel Minah you
didn't eat a lot of contests today and
you did eat a lot okay
stop cheating you know just stepped on
the scale to see what she would be any
that she was higher than I was no
adjusted so much 1 you ought to keep
that one huh right okay
I was one 93.7 last week error
holy cow it's just a little place it's
like between okay let's try again error
again holy cow wobbling too much one
92.3 not a lot to celebrate over but I
went down Nina yeah
I'm gonna take off my clothes do you
think I can close okay YouTube subscribe
for full breakfast usual McMuffin Browns
and coffee the guys know the drill by
now same thing
smoothie time it's green so it's kale
realized haven't had the protein shake
yet so I need to do that at some point
but just gonna do the smoothie for that
protein shake time I put it in the same
bottle as my smoothie after finish the
smoothie cuz I like that I can easily
shake it up I'm shaking the camera
shaking the camera this is not clumpy
usually just use a knife in any class
and I get clumps not bad cuz it tastes
good alright it's lunch time meme m8
soup that she's slurping what is this
chicken yeah tilapia fish well it's
yummy too meanwhile I am going through
my yearbooks to get rid of them and just
take out the pictures I've been keeping
the stack of yearbooks for years from
high school how many years you might see
some old pictures of Evan it's like I
actually signed my name on a bunch of
them that's it let's get it makes it
easier to find now that's me here and
I'm up here I'm not smiling
the one who's not smiling it looks like
he's gonna cry
anyway whatever this is great
five and I gotta go through these and
then get rid of the yearbooks and stop
carrying the from police the place so
excited so Nina has made a bunch of
smoothies
one two three four five six seven huge
containers these are huge huge
containers Oh a cow we love me that
she's special right there time we are at
found in salsa that's online you may
recognize on the channel
all right 11 o'clock still behind my
protein so having another quick protein
shake gonna watch some shows with my
wife we were wanted to watch suits but I
think we're out of episodes so maybe
prophet or shark tank
probably my those two we'll see all
right
day 29 tomorrow's last day pretty
excited pretty pumped starting the day
like always
protein shake how many steps yesterday
20,000 179 pretty good for a weekend and
two more days starting to sink in that
this is almost over though I think our
plugin continued anyway start the day
I'm ready it's a Monday morning all
right usual eggs and lentils and big-ass
smoothie wood kale and a bunch of
healthy stuff hungry so Nina had a rough
night last night was up super late and
so I'm going to grab a coffee for her
and surprise her at her work and give it
to her that's it you got to do nice
things to your wife all right last time
it's a big thing of meat got salads
somewhere under here with a whole bunch
of different meat on top I'm seeing at
least three different kinds of meat in
here there's little sausage pepper ATS
I think that's pork and that's turkey or
chicken 60 grams I asked me my lunch of
60 grams yes okay
time to eat
alright time for another smoothie this
is my third on the day I don't think I
filmed the second one it was on my way
to TBS to do the workout I might have I
drank it at the workout but number three
in the day and uni made a ton of
smoothie so I'm drinking down and
they're yummy alright got home from
Toronto and salsa Nina was helping
tonight she still got her shirt on says
family making some chicken and some
studies and she made me a smoothie
and I food some protein powder on top of
it that I got a mix in it's our last
night
tomorrow is weigh-in day for 30 days
how do you feel scary scary
alright good morning
we're tired very tired it's day 30 this
is it this is the big moment the main
part but we've even been you know
waiting for it so it's way they let's do
it nina started up one 27.5 and today
she is hundred and nineteen point nine
that point nine is pretty cool right
inside a 120 hundred ninety nine so Nina
last it basically eight pounds that's
pretty good eight pounds 8 pounds in 30
days Evan was two hundred and six point
six and today 191 point two
fifteen pounds in 30 days
so how do we do it summarize we eat
basically a high-protein diet a crazy
ahead and ice which kind of carbs a lot
yeah no types already minimal carbs but
not bad not like massive dehydrate
because the protein is just an insane
amount of protein that you have to eat
and then we worked out you know I did
like two or one and a half times a week
and then I ran on the spot for 20
minutes maybe three times a week that's
it and then we're gonna keep going yeah
I want to get down to 180 to 185 I know
a lot of you've already been posting
comments saying that I slimmed down and
what happened
I'm not sick this is on purpose it's
with intention so I'm I'm Michael stay
get to 180 to 185 and I'm one that you
too so slip that bad another another six
and a little bit pounds it's not that
bad what's your goal what the six pounds
to go who's gonna get there first cool
well thank you guys for watching most of
you think in the comments below
and believe I have a great day